[Music]
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum hi ryan hi
michael
and i'm a guitar hero real quick i was
thinking about how this i was trying to
figure
i was trying to figure out how to play
the old the theme song it's been so long
so it was like
it's my point of view come on you're
listening to
inside of you with michael rose
oh yeah kind of like that new one maybe
we should record that me and ryan
singing it
singing the theme song yeah i think
people would be upset i'm always weirded
out by
because you you learned a guitar
differently so i'm always like what the
hell chord is that but you just learned
backwards
well it makes sense because i am kind of
backwards if you meet me or obviously
you've been listening i'm a little
i'm a little backwards i play upside
down guitar it's how i learned i do kind
of everything ass backwards
probably life in general but you know
what's funny about that song you know
some people were like man that song
i don't like that song then other people
are like you know some fans or listeners
they play the song and they
it's kind of a staple i guess i don't
know and do we keep it do we do
we do a new song what do you guys think
he could write in say get rid of that
[ __ ] or uh whatever
good i like that you're wearing the
inside of your mask i don't i don't tell
you steel do you like it is it
comfortable
you can be honest oh it's nice i mean
i'd rather not wear a mask but
sure this is the world we live in so it
is but i mean as far as masks go
it's great great i like hearing that
merch yeah
merch it's all in the merch store it's
uh and new mugs i just had to order new
mugs the ones sold out
um so i said hey i'll autograph the mug
blah blah so those sold out so you know
we ordered more and there's a bunch of
other new stuff on the uh
inside e store but uh dude did you did
you feel the earthquake
[ __ ] yes what happened what did you
do when you
so wherever you are in the country if
you're not in la or the area that i'm in
you didn't experience this but
if you did i i have i have had like
experiences with earthquakes i remember
one in 99 or 2000 2001 maybe
whenever it was in california my friend
dave was crashed and i was running a
little place in studio city
and i remember when it really rattled
and he just
always tells the story all he heard was
there's nothing silence after and i got
then he hears
dave he's like yeah
dude and i'm like what do we do
[Laughter]
i don't know dude so we got under the
door frame i think that's kind of what
you're supposed to do maybe yeah
because i lived here during the 94 one
uh north ridge and i was living
living in sherman oaks horrifying yeah
uh
we hid under a table in the hall that's
what i remember doing well so this one
the other night it wasn't this one
how did you react well it sounded like a
meteor i don't know i was just startled
awake
uh and then i have this old tv that's on
my dresser
and like it's it's kind of big so like
that's like the first thing topple over
and amanda was sleeping next to me so
like
half asleep i went i just sort of like
like as like a shield over her i was
like but i was also like not
awake enough to realize like anything
that was happening so i was like
but in my subconscious i was trying to
be a hero but then i really wanted to go
back to sleep
yeah well my friend xander i i know i
was we were watching horror movie
via zoom last night and he was like
carrie and i
his wife loved them both
it was the weirdest thing because i
don't know what it's called but i i
think he had a name for it they got up
they jolted
up and they were both nauseous and like
almost throwing up and they were like
wow i didn't have that but what i did
was i deep sleep
and i don't have i'm not lucky enough to
have someone sleeping next to me
you know in fact my dog doesn't even
sleep next to me anymore
either of them i guess you know do you
blame them yeah
but i was out of a deep sleep just
like that sound and
i go i remember i got to the door frame
at first i ran to the dog and blanche
was like oh my god you know i was like
all right just stay there
go to the door frame and i remember i
got that voice back from 2001 i was like
lord lord uh i'm in your hands now i
don't have any control here i uh just
you know hey i make it quick
you know it was it was it was terrifying
and uh
and you got to think you know you're
california you live in california now i
mean i grew up in indiana but
we always have tornadoes i remember
tornadoes in indiana seeing two
uh funnel clouds that we call them
funnel clouds the tornadoes freak me out
more than that
oh my god seeing these things in the
backyard about i don't know a quarter of
a quarter of a half mile away i was like
oh my gosh
i have no idea how you guys deal with
that uh yeah and i've had yeah a lot of
friends but i had a friend who lost his
dad to it
at people's houses i mean you hear all
that stuff but uh this one you got to
think that
uh the big california one's coming you
got to think you know
it's due you hope it's not but you know
there's going to be one you know there's
going to be another one a big one
yeah that's what we keep being told and
yeah and then there was a brush fire
about it that day there's a brush fire
helicopters dropping
right near where i live and i'm like my
buddy harlan you know dumb and dumber
the cop that picks you know he's like
you guys drinking on some of grandpa's
cough medicine
he he uh leaves a voice memo yes hey bud
i don't know if you noticed but
uh the choppers are around they're
dropping water and whatever [ __ ] they
drop
and uh it's kind of right near you so uh
look i don't know what's gonna happen
but you might want to grab your laptop
or your belongings
and i'm like what is going on earthquake
this morning
brushfire covid all the [ __ ] that's
going on in the world i'm thinking
i mean is it not i guess it's normal to
think is this end of days you start to
think that but you gotta
we can't think like that you can't live
in the future no i talk about that you
just gotta go hey
what do you got what do you got throw it
at me and i'm gonna do the best i can to
deal with it and you hope that it just
things get better and lucky i mean look
that's life you know you have these
highs you have these lows you have these
but the things you can't control are the
toughest right the things that you know
you can't control death you can't
control uh you know
uh earthquakes or tornadoes or
so uh you know and then i just found out
a friend's dad died my other friend
close friend
his dad got covered went to the hospital
had pneumonia
he's doing better now um
oh also big a big shout out to mr lally
tom lolly senior
i love you mr lally uh you're a
fantastic human being and
i'm wishing you the best and thinking of
you he knows that because they text him
constantly hey it's rosenbaum
all right mike you know it's so cliche
and people do that when something tragic
happens or
but it's it's it's pretty easy to just
text somebody or call somebody to say i
want you to know i love you
that's it that's it that that's it it's
it's it's good for everyone
um i immediately uh did that with my
sibling so i don't talk to a ton
and uh my brother who i hadn't talked to
in a while said you know text me
something really nice and it was uh
it was nice it was almost like
self-deprecating sort of like hey i know
i've sort of been a little bit of a [ __ ]
up whatever
my older brother and he said something
that was kind of profound and
i'm not going to say it probably as
profoundly as he
texted it to me but it was nice um so
yeah look uh
also a shout out before we get into our
guest and this is a fantastic guest i
know i say that but uh
also you guys know that you heard it a
million times
whatever you could do to support the
podcast you're doing it by listening but
if you're here for this guest
only subscribe listen watch on youtube
it's all free
to do that and if you want to join
patreon which by the way my patreons are
the reason why
we're doing the show because uh you know
supporting the podcast in other ways and
you know there's a bunch of great stuff
that i i give like certain tears get
questions with me and inside of me and i
created a character that talks to me
like a
female version of me a uh an australian
if that's what you want to call it his
accent goes in and out but he asks me
questions
from the patrons in those and i create
these
so home alone cause you're not here a
lot and i create these characters that
talk to me and ask me questions so
that's all part of that and then uh
some tears get to ask the guest
questions called [ __ ] talking so i go
this is from my patreon this is so and
so we do zooms there's a bunch of [ __ ]
it's great
started this community there's a huge
amount of friendships that have been
created
so patreon inside of you patreon if you
haven't heard of it check it out i think
you'll love it supports the podcast and
and just uh you know text your friends
email your friends to listen
or watch or and subscribe and support
the podcast
at insideepodcast on instagram and at
insideoutpod
on twitter so i want to thank them and a
big shout out
we did a stage at rob danson and i we're
trying to make a new album so we do
these stages these live performances on
staging and tons of people come and uh
the top bidder or whatever uh two lovely
ladies
uh vicki garcia and lisa jordan
i want to give you my love right now
vicki
garcia lisa jordan top bidders thank you
so much
and thanks for supporting uh our music
and um i want to make an album and i got
lastly i will say this
if it wasn't for the this podcast which
i almost quit many times
in the beginning we weren't getting
anybody to listen i was like what am i
doing
i mean this is just a blow to the ego
no one gives a [ __ ] and then i just
stuck with it and i'm so glad i did
because
and the music i really started two years
ago and uh you know the patreon i
started six months ago but if i
wasn't doing these things what would i
be doing now
i wouldn't be looking at this inside of
you pillow that uh
kristen and um leah made for me with all
the names of the guests and these
pillows and
but i wouldn't be doing all you know so
it's all the love and support
and you know um you know when i talk
about it i mean there's some podcasts
that are huge
you know that just get in and then
there's some podcasts there but i think
everybody nowadays all these new
celebrities since the kova they're
starting podcasts so they're all
podcasters so
there's a lot to listen to and i'm like
you know to be able to come back and
listen to me and support me in this
podcast and
us ryan um and bryce uh it's really um
it's it's amazing and i'm so grateful
and i'm glad i stuck with it and
uh it's growing and it makes me happy
so again thank you ryan i've said it
before i'll say it again you're welcome
i'm glad you stuck with it yeah yeah i
am too i mean uh
what the [ __ ] would i be doing uh this
guest is um someone i've known for a
while
also you should know he's the only one
that you see
um in person that i've been doing
because i've done all zooms now he was
it was in person because we did it
months ago
because we didn't think we did a bunch
in a row at the end of january beginning
of february and we just sort of been and
then when covet hit we decided to do
some zoom zooms
we have sort of held onto this one for a
while we held on we're like you know
this could go on for a long time longer
than we
anticipated so uh yeah so this is uh
you'll see him but uh he's not wearing a
mask because this is way before covid
so uh he's a great guy and i didn't i
didn't know him that well
other than you know just kind of really
friendly but man uh he
opens up man he opens up so much about
his um
biological father and and his and kurt
russell who raised him in goldie and
uh it was you know i didn't expect this
interview to be more than 50 minutes
and it went longer because i was so
interested in him and he was so open and
fun and i
loved i loved talking to him i really
loved
i i think you could hear my voice while
we're talking as it gets goes on
so oliver hudson uh he's been in a lot
of stuff
uh you know his sister kate they have a
podcast
and uh let's just get into it i think
you're gonna really dig this uh let's
get inside of oliver
hudson it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
[Music]
rosenbaum
of you with michael rosenbaum was not
recorded in front of a live studio
audience
how do we know each other i'm pretty
sure that i went out with your wife
oh yeah a long long time ago and i
really liked her and she dumped me and
then she dated someone else and then met
you and then you got married yeah
that was yeah yeah yeah no women that's
it i left the house she was at the house
i was like i'm gonna talk about
rose and bomb and your whole
relationship did you say that to you yes
she goes don't
don't bring it out i mean we really
didn't have a relationship
for you know what it was it was one of
the first times in my life
not the first i've i've had a lot of
these moments where i am just
intimidated by a woman
she was so i felt she was like nobody's
perfect but i thought she was beautiful
and sweet and smart and cool and
i was like don't [ __ ] and i just and
that's why i think i'm single
that's why i think a lot of my
confidence is not because of aaron no no
no
no i know what i know what you mean i
know what you mean yeah no she's
she's amazing you missed out you blew it
i mean you really didn't blow it yeah i
mean
i don't know what happened but i'm happy
that she
came into my world because that woman is
did you know right away you're perfect
did you know right away
yeah well you know how it is man like we
met
actually don't say wb in an acting class
it's just how it's worse you know um but
i had a girlfriend i was dating
vanessa shaw remember vanessa shaw no
she was an actress around town for me
she actually she lived right up here
and we were friends for a minute
yeah and then she dated simon rex
for about six months that's what i
thought that's what happened right after
me simon started dating yes it was
like of course he's way better looking
he's got a great body he's got that
italian look on his face yeah he's got
that just a good looking
italian look on his face
god damn it he looks so he
he looks american but at the time he had
an italian look on his face such a good
looking guy
yeah so she did it for six months she
did it for six months and then we we got
together but
like anything else when we first got
together of course she was great i
didn't know her she was just
sexy as [ __ ] and i wanted to you know
see her naked i mean that's really what
it was
let's be honest no and then uh we got
we we made it happen and uh that was
that i mean
and it was good i was concerned at first
but you weren't good
yeah you were quick yeah
yeah who wouldn't be quick yeah i was
quick i'm quick all the time
i've been married for 19 years and i'm
still quick sometimes you know what's
wrong with that
you know what i say here's what i say
ryan there's nothing wrong with it i
look at a woman if that happens and i
just go because someone told me this
works i go
compliments to you and then she's like
that's not gonna work no
you [ __ ] are you're in your 40s you
shouldn't be coming like i need
something no no no dude i mean i i swear
to god i've been with aaron for 19 years
and sometimes
i don't i feel i don't know what happens
does she say three pumps in and i'm like
holy [ __ ]
slow down what is it you think with uh
premature ejaculation
what what i i think i mean i can speak
for myself but
men i think are very very worked up
visual
super visual yeah the minute i get into
the zone and i
see it all happening yeah i'm like i'm
doing this
oh [ __ ] yeah it's happening right now
and i can see
everything isn't that something yeah and
i'm like it's all beautiful and hot and
i'm like okay well
don't look look away or something that
is a beautiful vagina and your penis is
going in and out of you
no and by the way your penises never
look better oh cause the lighting
the lighting is good it's a nice sheen
oh you know maybe a moonlight a shaft of
moonlight
a shaft
it's it's it's real i mean that those
visuals dude i'm glad you i'm glad you
you
you go early yeah i mean not all the
time but she loves you she's good with
it she's like hey he's going to give me
he's going to do it do it better here's
the thing i think men
men have a misconception though men
think
that women just want to have sex for
hours
that is just not the case and that won't
be the case if they're dating me
well good i would just happen let's
promote you
promote your premature ejaculation i can
never i can never have if you're a woman
out there and you're thinking oh man
rosenbaum's kind of cute
uh i want to have sex with them just
know you'll never have
hours of sex good no one will want that
if you're counting
cumulatively in a decade then you're
going to get about an hour now but
you're going to get maybe a couple hours
but not but go ahead in the moments that
things are going really well too well
actually well for me where i'm like oh
i'm in a zone now i
i can i can last for however long i want
which happens
aaron is like okay let's get this
[ __ ] over with
should i put some um should i put some
uh jennifer aniston friends
exactly season four she's ex she's done
she
it it's she it's a good eight to eight
to eleven minutes
and then boom do you watch any porn we
used to
is it does that mess up things no no
no no no no i don't i don't watch porn
anymore personally
i i quit i don't even i mean i quit very
very seldom
i swear i quit about uh a year and a
half ago you say you quit like you're an
addict
i wasn't an actual addict but it was
it was it you you use it to self-soothe
meaning like
i'm bored what can i do right now oh
i'll jerk off it's gonna pass the time
and much like smoking a cigarette
i quit that as well yeah i don't smoke
either you know what i mean yeah but
that's why i smoked i was like you know
especially on movie sets or tv sets it
was like okay in between takes and what
am i gonna do now i'm bored i'll smoke a
cigarette
and that's the same with jerking off
dude jerking off it was like okay i'm
home alone for an hour and a half two
hours
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do even while
you're married you're jerking off yeah
not anymore though dude
i have let me tell you something yeah
tell me since november
of last year i have jerked off probably
i don't know 10 to 13. since when a year
a year about oh just over a year okay i
just uh
i don't know i don't know i'm going to
tell you something i'm not i'm sort of
done with it and by the way i'm not
trying not to do it right
i'm not trying not to i just have no
desire but my sex life with aaron is
on fire all right see this is look i
i'm not saying this to just make you
feel better because not that you need to
feel but you're first of all you're
married you have three kids you have a
great life you're working
you're getting laid you're doing all
these great things so yeah
i'm i yeah i wish i was in your shoes i
really do
but uh i i've never been a jerk offer
mm-hmm
jerk off but i've never been a jerk
officer i mean i remember
i just never i mean i'm sure i jerked
off a little bit in college
yeah but i've never been one that like i
gotta masturbate
it just it was one of those things where
like now it's been a couple weeks since
you got laid it's like uh
yeah all right i'll jerk off you know
the problem with me is i get i have 80d
yeah so sometimes it's just like i'm
trying to jerk off and i'm thinking
is the i think i just heard the wash is
done you get distracted
i gotta put the clothes in the dryer
right is that my dog down there maybe
something mini shoe down there
no it's just a it's a limp it's hard
it's lit it's like a [ __ ] sling
terrible you get distracted forget it
forget it
no i agree i i just when i was younger i
was
when i i had i got mono in high school i
got mono a couple years ago so
mono dude i'll tell you about that that
[ __ ] me up man you know justin bieber
you see that that happened
yeah well go ahead oh so i had mono and
and i was home for [ __ ]
two months she took it off you had the
strength
oh dude i i i was so bored i jerked off
like ten
times a day i mean i must have had
monogamy
well i can sit on a couch and get hard
you know i mean that's so that's easy
with a fever yeah you know i'm sleepy
but i can still jerk off
yeah i didn't get mono when i was a kid
and so uh
maybe because i didn't ever you know
this is called the kissing disease which
is kind of [ __ ] it's like you can
get it off
a lip balm and get off whatever but i
had fight or flight for so long because
i was go i was stressing myself out not
being able to deal with stress
that uh i was a lead on a show and then
i was trying to stand up in front of
crowds with big comedians and i'd never
done it i was in a band for the first
time performing on stage i just did
everything
at once and i was not when i say fight
or flight
i was perpetually consistently
in heart heart heart heart like always
nervous ner like always on edge
going up till you know two in the
morning getting back home
and something happened just the perfect
storm while i was i was in germany i
came back
and i went to the doctor and it took me
they go look for adult mono mono
[Music]
[Laughter]
but it i'm telling you for adults over a
year for me to really start to feel my
who i am again so
you had epstein-barr as well right i
mean because that goes so yeah
the whole thing but it was brutal and i
had like high mercury and i had like
real [ __ ] like i got
i didn't believe it because i was like i
don't have mono anyway then they thought
i had [ __ ] lyme disease so they sent
me
so one of my friends like you should go
to this lime specialist so i went to
this lime specialist she goes you have
lime
then i went to another lime specials you
have lime i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] this i know
i don't have lime
she's giving me penicillin shots in my
ass how do you know you don't have it
when you have two doctors tell you
you're i'm not saying lyme disease is
is a hoax because it's not but uh
there's a lot of doctors out there that
kind of just
like oh yeah well you look at your your
results so the first thing i did was
went to my general practitioner again i
said listen man
there's no way i have [ __ ] mono and
lyme disease and
babesia or some [ __ ] [ __ ] i i've
never been bitten
he goes i'm gonna send you to the
infectious diseases center
over at cedars and i go great
i'm excited about this yeah yeah and i
went there and this guy was like one of
the heads
and he looked through every booklet of
all these tests
he goes you know let me tell you
something
you could listen to me or not
i don't think you have lyme disease i
think you got mono
and i think you're tired and i think uh
you're gonna get better
i don't want you to take these tests
anymore if you took a lot of these tests
that they're
they're giving you i would show up
positive in some of these tests
a lot of people would be d i don't think
you have mo
or lyme move on with your life yeah and
i did and from that day forward i
started getting better
oh wow and i'm not saying lime's fake
i'm saying
if they say you have lyme go to a
specialist disease control
and the lyme people will say no doctors
say it's [ __ ] and some do but this
guy goes i've seen lyme
i've seen it i believe it i don't think
you have lyme
and well you had auto you are autoimmune
i mean i've got autoimmune
disease of some sort i just want to know
or whatever what
i was [ __ ] man well then who the hell
are you supposed to believe any of these
days
you know yeah i mean who knows man but i
hit a wall and it was scary because
were you able to work i mean were you
able to function i mean how did you
no i was i was pretty [ __ ] man i was
like i couldn't i think i did some
things but i was like i'm not at my best
i don't have the confidence because i
always feel like i'm going to be too
tired yeah how am i going to finish this
i just i i still functioned where i
tried to sleep
and i try to watch movies and read and
you know if my friends did something but
i felt so self-conscious like
i know i look like [ __ ] i know i don't
look like myself
i know they're looking at me like i feel
they're looking at me
and they're just being nice and some of
my friends will just be like
dude man you look like [ __ ] yeah i'm
like [ __ ] this why am i going out
so i just looked like did it did it give
you any anxiety
oh yeah yeah okay i'm telling you that's
when i [ __ ] hit a wall with anxiety i
think that started the whole thing that
that anxiety kind of just went boom
that's just a real dude i mean
it's really anxiety uh well i mean i i
went in my 20s
i had a year of debilitating anxiety
like lose my [ __ ] can't leave the house
every time i left the house i was
throwing up you know
i was still trying to be an actor i was
just sort of getting started
nervous about auditioning nervous about
everything i didn't know
so it it it hit me actually i was with
my friend john going into crazy girls of
all places
right is that a department store yeah
it's a department store on uh fairfax
and
they give good hand jobs to the
department store
right which was owned previously by uh
slash or something no no it was the uh
the dude who was the
this is going to be the worst way to
explain who this guy is crazy girls he
was the deputy cop and scream
david arkansas that's it i think he
might have owned one of those did he
really i think
i cannot believe you described david the
deputy congratulations
how would you describe it i [ __ ] got
it i mean i got how did you describe him
uh what would you have said he's married
he's a guy
brother of the christian cat yeah
exactly for
the brother patricia i couldn't remember
the name
but anyway so i'm walking in and he my
friend john is in front of me
and my heart just out of nowhere
explodes or so
boom it put me on a knee because i was
like
you had a heart attack i thought i was
having a heart attack and i was like
john and he didn't hear me and i
i took it five minutes outside like i
didn't die and i was gathering myself
i went in i had a vodka i was like i
need something to i don't know what the
[ __ ] just happened
yeah and i was like i got to get out of
here something's weird
that started almost a year
of intense anxiety to where i would wake
up every day
and feel like i couldn't breathe
tingling down your arms oh dude i know
that i would go outside
and throw up and i was surfing a lot of
the time but i was not going to let it
affect my life so i would go out
and i would go under the lineup and and
[ __ ] throw up and stuff but try to
catch waves and
and then i was i was i was still trying
to be an actor so i was going
it because to [ __ ] that it was gnarly
it was so intense
meditation um writing in journals
and then i i got through most of it and
then i there was still a little edge and
then i took
antidepressants i was i took celexa i
was on celexa for a while what is celexa
selex is an antidepressant that's not
like you go celexa can you
turn on the radio that's not it that's
funny no what is it
uh it's antidepressants it's an
anti-present anti-anxiety right
it's an ant it's called an
antidepressant it's an ssri it's an
uptake
so it's a serotonin uptake inhibitor
right exactly
i think i took something i didn't have a
depression but it was good for my to
take the edge off of mine it really
worked oh dude it [ __ ] are you still
on it
no so i got off of that and then i
i was working in nashville for two years
away from my kids
on the show nashville yeah and i just
had my third kid rio
she was 10 10 days old and i have to go
for two years to [ __ ] nashville so
now i'm flying back and forth
every chance that's gonna give you
anxiety it it took a toll
and then i had a another moment and i
said [ __ ] it's back
oh dude i had a boom i had a freak out
no selection holy [ __ ] i didn't
then i went onto lexapro and so now i'm
on lexapro but i'm weaning off it's been
three years things are good
so i'm trying to just sort of so what
triggers this i'm getting so it's
different for people but i think
like for me when you're not sleeping
enough
when you're flying too much when you're
not taking care of yourself you're not
exercising
when you're allowing yourself if all
these things if you're not doing all
these things
then you know you can't fight off this
stuff dude totally well for the
there was two different reasons why in
the two separate parts of my life the
first one was just trying to be an actor
in my early 20s right my mom's a movie
star my dad's a movie star kate is now a
movie
star and i am trying to [ __ ] do this
i'm not putting my all into it at all
i'm i am just sort of at that point
no dude but still i have i've put this
expectation and this pressure on myself
and it's just not going well but
i was not i wasn't going full speed
because the harder you try the further
it is to fall
you know if i study for an audition with
an inch of its life
and i go and i [ __ ] bomb it's going
to hurt
if i don't study and i just go hung over
and read the lines in my car as i'm
going to the audition and i don't get it
oh [ __ ] i didn't try i have an excuse
good right and that's where i was
in the latter and and then it just
caught up to me
and through therapy and through you know
meditation
and my journal writing it all came into
it all came into view as to why this was
happening to me at this time it was sort
of like a quarter life crisis you know i
think john mayer
maybe it's a called alive crash is that
i don't know
that's all right why georgia is the same
georgia that's the song he says the
quarter-life president
never heard it before then i didn't even
know that last time yeah
but now we're in our mid-line we're in
our mid-life crisis
that's right you know i kind of had one
i also think just communication
i mean there was a lot that i held in in
my later years going to nashville you
know
it's just the authenticity you know
holding [ __ ]
in not being truthful to yourself to
people around you
um not being expressive not being
vulnerable the way i should be
vulnerable i mean all of these things
being away from my family i think that's
what led to this city
you know what's happening right now i'm
gonna be honest with you why i knew you
were coming in here i was excited and
senior for a while i always liked you
just a genuine dude always liked you we
didn't hang out but i like
we had moment we had we had moments and
some laughs but just you know
yeah but now just 20 minutes into this
[Music]
i i just i'm learning so much and i and
i
i i just i love that you're so open
about this [ __ ] because this is like
it's important dude i
i you know [ __ ] everybody else listening
it's really about me
mm-hmm that's right that's right
it's just it's ringing in my ears like
it seems like you know i've talked about
this through all the other pockets but
this is what i think we're all listening
we're going
you're giving us little things maybe
it's just one thing we learned from you
but you're being so open about how you
beat your anxiety
that when something's not working for
someone else then go you know oliver
hudson did this he
journaled about how he was feeling and
he
did this and this maybe i'll give that a
shot yeah maybe i'll try differently and
that's really the key is to just
do whatever it takes no totally and by
the way i've always been an open book
and i think it's important now that's
why i love what you're doing i love what
we're doing in the space
right thank you it's time to [ __ ]
tell the truth
i think we can you can help people with
your truth and your authenticity
who gives a [ __ ] what people think you
know what i mean like that's what i'm
getting over yeah who's gonna listen to
this right now and say oh my god oliver
had anxiety
or oliver you know took antidepressants
i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
i mean that that stuff does not affect
me by the way
by the way the fact that you're saying
that now i'm not sure i believe you
completely why not now i know i believe
you
i believe that you care what everyone
else thinks hang on
less than me but i'm not sure you're
completely like
it doesn't somehow affect you okay
you're not wrong okay here's how you're
not wrong
when it comes to the stuff that we were
just talking about in my personal life
and the things that i
believe in or my truth you don't give a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] i agree with
you okay okay i'm with you now again as
an
as a performer as an entertainer as an
actor as i do and that has been my
downfall
me too as an actor i think that i have
not
touched my potential because fear of
fear
a hundred percent how do we get over
here how do we get over that and that
and on my 24th birthday kurt my stepdad
kurt russell russell right he pulls me
in and this is right when i started
acting i mean i was 21 22 actually 24 is
when i got my first gig
and i was going to do this job in my one
of my first big jobs
and i was so scared and so nervous and
by the way i still get so [ __ ]
nervous
when i go at work of course it makes me
crazy
i would be so great if i didn't have to
do no but it's part of you i don't want
not to be a part of it totally yeah
you're this much yeah i'm i'm so with
you i'm like i don't
don't give me that it's a part of you or
use it [ __ ] a little bit
just let me be free and then i'll be
good right but he told me
he goes here's the thing the talent is
all there the problem is
with you because you just have to stop
giving a [ __ ] what people think about
you
and it's true
but that's him okay and this is what i
learned later on
i was always for 10 years trying not to
give a [ __ ]
i'm trying not to give a [ __ ] because
kurt truly doesn't give a [ __ ]
about what people think about him in the
acting space and my brother wyatt
russell
right now player goalie i love that
goalie he's crushing it
he's an actor and [ __ ] a crushing it
right now right
his confidence doesn't give a [ __ ] he's
through the roof
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like i'm
going to do it the way i want to do it
and if you don't think it's good
i don't give a [ __ ] i tried to emulate
that
the problem is the realization i had was
that's not inherently that's not who i
am that's not your makeup
exactly that's who these people are but
that's not who i am and once i
recognize that it was sort of liberating
in a way
it's okay to give a [ __ ] but just don't
let it
rule you rule you right you can care
you know but there's a way to sort of
curb the anxiety around
that caring so much an expectation you
know what i have to say this
i was selfishly thinking while you were
talking
oh my god kurt had a conversation with
kurt russell
snake pluskin and he looked at him and
he said words of wisdom don't give a
[ __ ] and from then on
oliver ruled the world and then i was
gonna say
is there any way kirk can have this
conversation with me
that's what went through my [ __ ]
psychotic mind if it worked for you
but okay so but it didn't so the point
is it didn't i had to discover it myself
right because you this is this is basic
[ __ ]
education here this is be yourself
and this translates to every job every
year this is who you are ryan if you're
shy you're a little awkward which you
are
right yeah i can sense that who gives a
[ __ ] because you're brilliant i've seen
his [ __ ] he's brilliant look at his
youtube videos and
he's just he hasn't even scratched the
surface i know what this guy can do
right now he's working with me and
hopefully for a while
but you know get the [ __ ] out of a
record button tell you what though no i
know
exactly but i think that there's like
hey
rosie you're a little [ __ ] you're a
neurotic
you look at your genes dude you come
from manic depression and
crazy [ __ ] and valium induced rages and
all this whatever
yeah like but this is who you are yeah
try to be as healthy as you can and you
know what if you fall apart every once
in a while it's okay
i'm with you when you say the anxiety
stuff and this
i am much better i don't care going i
talk about it openly about me going to a
wellness center me doing that [ __ ]
please but when it comes to certain
things
like you know just offer this movie i'm
like i don't think i could do it
i don't think i could do it right now i
don't think i can learn 100 pages of
lines in two weeks and then go
and some people you don't have to learn
200 pages you just go the night before i
don't work like that yeah i'm going to
stress myself to the [ __ ] death of me
if i don't have time to prepare and be
[ __ ] great
i will freak myself out not knowing
lines give me a [ __ ] earwig
yeah do whatever there's all this [ __ ]
that comes with it but you know what
maybe i should embrace it maybe go rosie
you're [ __ ] right yeah why would you
put yourself through hell
for that yeah why yeah do your podcast
yeah wait for the right thing yeah
develop your show
talk to people go to some cons enjoy
life why kill yourself
yeah yeah unless somebody can just fix
me or
but but no no no but if you're running
away from it because
of of those fears and that's not the
right place to be i don't think
you know what i mean like if this
movie's a good movie and it's a great
character and it's something that you
want to do
but the idea of going to do it makes you
too nervous and now you're not going to
do it because of that well there's other
things like
you know chicago dead of winter outside
yeah you know
is there money had surgeries
i like the guy's a good writer yeah you
know i want to do his other movie i
probably will
right if he doesn't listen to this or if
he listens to it i'll know that i
respect him by the way lines you say
memorization of lines that is the
biggest problem for me
for me it's not about whether i'm a good
actor or not it's like oh my god can i
remember the lines and if i don't
everyone's going to think oh this
[ __ ] guy doesn't know his lines and
now we're not going to lunch on that's a
fear
yeah is it is it but it's about the
lines and it is logical though is it
real can you do you have muscle memory
where
it becomes easier or is it always hard
no it becomes easier it becomes easier
and all and it's also again sort of
saying you know what here's what i tell
myself
we're all here to do a job on this movie
set right
we need craft service for food we need
grips we need electricians we need
everyone
everyone [ __ ] up how many times this is
like all right wait wait cut cut we got
to reset this light
or the dp says this isn't working we i
need i need 15 more minutes so the
action
i'm allowed to [ __ ] up and i'm allowed
to say oh [ __ ] sorry guys i'm going up
on my line
six times five i know that but
there is a part of me that um
wants this is what i have to change i
just you're making me realize this
there's a part of me that i'm never late
i hit my marks every time i come in i
don't even need my script i read it i
[ __ ] know it i don't even want to
rehearse let's [ __ ] shoot it
i know it inside out i put so much
pressure on myself i [ __ ] live it
and then i do it that i don't want to
[ __ ] up
if i feel lost out there like i don't
know these lines
that is terrifying to me that is like
dropping the ball you are a failure
they're all going to see through your
[ __ ] you're going to embarrass yourself
i remember there was one taking a movie
that took me 13 takes
to say a line because i was still in my
head that i couldn't even think of the
line oh yeah i could not even think
that just stop for a second breathe
think about
it didn't matter what the line was it
wasn't coming out it came out somehow
and i think god
jumped in my body for a second yeah he
helped me out right in that moment and
this movie that made no money
he helped me yeah dude no i know that
when you just go completely blank i have
a story about that i was doing a sitcom
rules of engagement of engagement right
for seven years yes live audience
and i was we were well into the series i
forget what season it was
there was a scene i had spayed patrick
warburton right right
and i i had to do this scene right
center stage in front of the whole
[ __ ] audience there's like 2 300
people
however many people i forget the line
okay i forget it again now
it's in your head in my head and now i'm
done
and there's no one there to save me no
the ep the executive producer writer
director no one said all right you know
what let's just give it a second or
every i was i was just twisting in the
wind
i realized in that moment that i had to
take this into my own hands because the
audience now went from laughing
that i [ __ ] up a line because they do
now it's quiet
embarrassing and now i'm six takes in
and i cannot get these lines out
and now everyone is feeling for me and
this audience dude you
take two or three you're probably
already thinking that moment's going to
come
100 yeah they come in they're gonna
laugh now yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] it up
again yeah you're already anticipating
your vlog
and it was it was like a page and a half
scene hitting marks and running around
all four cameras rolling
finally i said all right and i i took
control of
everything because i couldn't deal with
it anymore i said here's what's gonna
[ __ ] happen i lost it i snapped
you did oh i said okay bianca who is my
co-star i was like
go let's start the scene cameras are you
[ __ ] rolling keep them rolling let's
go you ready
scriptures arise what's the big thing
she tells me the line
i do the thing i got do whatever my
sitcom
thing is i hit the mark all right what
move the cameras i know we're
repositioning
what's the next line tells it to me i
did it in four parts
and just went through it like that and
said hey tell me the line
okay okay great blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah finished it up but go all
right all right we're done
that's it we're done everybody's like oh
my god oh oh well the audience started
to
cheer you know because it was there was
a release of something sort of
moving on finally hey he [ __ ] like
right
exactly right but it was that moment of
i am so [ __ ] and into control i had to
i had to save myself it was desperation
time no one was reaching out to me and
saying oh dude let's just
hey olly you want like 10 minutes to do
it you want 10 minutes that's probably
worse 10 minutes would have been worse i
can't think straight it's just more
you know what i was thinking you're
gonna do this is what i would have done
and i think
this this happened like in a lot i was
doing a sitcom and i said the line ball
and my dad was there that night and
that's a big thing because like you know
yeah talk about feeling like failure oh
yeah yeah so
i'm there and i do this thing and they
go uh rosie
let's take it back let's do that again
and i remember i stumbled and i was like
and the director was like all right cool
moving on and i knew i knew i didn't
i didn't care yeah i'm like i don't care
if he's moving on yeah i don't care if
it's sucked i want to move on
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] you know and so
i think in that situation
i might have been like you know what
guys we could always pick this up when
you're not here you know the scene
you've seen it
we're going to pick it up after the show
i'm not going to hold up your time
because i don't know my goddamn lines
i make a joke and be done with it after
take two yeah we're gonna do it
afterwards i'm not doing it now that's
what's happening yeah uh
okay they would have listened to you
yeah yeah yeah oh for sure for sure
why do we get so terrified i don't know
because because we care we care
yeah but we care about we care too much
or we i think
i just care what i care how people
perceive me
inside of you is supported by better
help online counseling
now's the time to do it and i'll tell
you these guys are stuck around because
i think people
see how important it is to talk to
someone if i don't talk to someone
which i'm alone a lot and if you're
alone a lot you're not talking to
anybody
start talking to your dog start talking
to yourself better help
you better get help better help online
counseling uh
look if you're struggling with anxiety
or depression uh you know i've talked
about it i talk about it all the time
i'm not embarrassed by it uh the guests
that come on here aren't embarrassed
about talking about it
uh you've heard them talk about it
better help offers online licensed
professional counselors who are trained
to listen and help
counselor specializes in in many areas
like i said with the anxiety grief
relationship conflicts you name it you
talk with a counselor in a safe and
private online environment
at your convenience from wherever you're
comfortable and that's that's huge
because a lot of people don't want
anybody to know they're
and that we're trying to normalize uh
this but like
this is private this is you can talk to
someone and it
no one has to know if that's how you
feel you're a private person
i tell the world my [ __ ] easily schedule
secure video or phone sessions with your
therapist plus exchange
unlimited messages everything you share
is of course confidential and if any
reason you're unhappy you don't like
this you don't like your counselor you
can request it
uh no additional charge um at any time
join a million people or more that are
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced better
health professional
with so many people using better help
they're currently recruiting additional
counselors
in all 50 states it's obviously working
better help is an affordable option and
our listeners get 10 percent off your
first month
with the discount code inside get
started today at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's better
h-e-l-p dot com slash
i-n-s-i-d-e
look how many times in interviews over
your life has it and it's a wonder too
you talk about the pressures you talk
about you know you're 20 and like here's
kate
has his huge success and here's my my
dad's kurt russell and my mom's uh you
know goldie hawn it's like
of course it's like how are you not
going to compare and go
yeah i guess i should be a movie star
it's that easy
i should just be a movie star and you're
working and all these things
sure i mean i but the thing is it's not
what i wanted to do i mean i i wanted to
make movies like when my
producers direct produce right that's
what i did when i was a kid
while kate was doing plays i had cameras
and filters and squibs and blood and
[ __ ] latex
horror movie oh i loved that [ __ ] you
and i should
i loved all that [ __ ] i grew up on on
horror you know
and that's what i did and then i went to
college for two years
left boulder i was just i was gonna kill
myself there i was just drinking and
skiing pretty much
then i i worked at uh as a pa for two
years
production assistant on movies and then
i went in an sc
summer intensive thing which was really
fun and then i was like i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm gonna do for you you
had to know you were good-looking
because i remember seeing you when i was
you know and i was like yeah that guy's
really she's a cute
guy good looking cute clean cut guy so
you had looks i mean
your mom's goldie hawn was bill hudson a
good-looking guy
yeah yeah you have you don't talk to him
i know that right there's no
we do now we do now a little bit yeah i
mean
it's a crazy story i mean i i was um
i was working in new orleans and it was
father's day
and i posted something with my sick
sort of dark sense of humor and it was a
picture of my sister and my dad
and myself during happy times and i the
caption was happy abandonment day
and i thought it was funny i still think
it was funny but
but you hadn't talked to him in how long
oh ever i haven't seen him in 13 14
years
who would have thought that bill hudson
was on the instagram well he wasn't but
what happened was
is the press picked it up and then it
caught fire
and then it all went viral and then of
course because my sister
is my sister she got included into the
whole thing
the comments on my that post just
[ __ ] started stacking up
i mean it turned into this whole thing
people being nice are people kind of
both yeah both supportive and like both
both and then
and i was like oh [ __ ] i was just trying
to be funny you know did your mom think
it was funny
i mean she was like oliver ugh you know
she did one of those
and kate same thing kate was like what
are you doing i'm like i don't know
she's trying to
make a [ __ ] show again i'm 43.
when this happened oh no this was i was
uh
i was like 39. okay so it wasn't like
that was recently ish
right right so then my dad uh comes out
with an article on like the daily mail
saying
i you know that my kids are dead to me
and i mean he he was very hurt by it
because he had heard about it he's not
on instagram
and then i wrote him a text i got his
number and wrote him a long
text and uh it wasn't mean but
it was it was stern and i apologized but
didn't in a way
you know i said look who are you to be
dead to me you have been yeah this is
what i'm saying like who are you to be
angry about this dad i mean let's get
real for a [ __ ] second
and it led to a phone call which was a
three-hour phone call which was
really an amazing phone call no no tears
but it was
you know it was i i sort of put him on
the witness stand
you know what i mean i was just grilling
him it was just talking about my life
and you know everything and i'm i'm a
man now i'm no longer even in my 20s
when we were
when we talked last i mean things are
different
it was a great conversation i finished
this job i went back to la and had a
an amazing breakfast with him at
patrick's roadhouse what was that like
walking to see you haven't seen your dad
in years yeah he was crazy i mean were
you
did you get anxious before a little bit
yeah but but i was uh
i felt strong i you know it was
interesting i i um
i went from being sort of well i made
myself the victim
really even through my childhood because
you know as a kid you think you did
something wrong and you think it's your
fault obviously in the sort of
after-school special way but you know
you know it's not
but now i felt different i felt like i
was in the power
seat and i was able to go in you talked
to me
that's yeah so and i i went in there did
you give him a hug
yeah yeah i went in there he had long
scraggly hair there was a big white
beard
and i was like oh my god and he and i
and you know i'm getting older now and i
was like holy [ __ ] i look just like this
[ __ ] i mean it was
the eyes of that no yeah the eye i've
never seen what he looks like but yeah
the ice i mean
and i gave him a big hug and we had
breakfast and it was an amazing talk and
then we
sat outside of patrick's roadhouse and
smoked a pack of cigarettes together
which was
amazing and uh even that was part of the
catharsis you know what i mean we're
just
just the moment with your dad that
you've never had it was beautiful i mean
we connected on a really interesting
level
he was opening up to me about certain
things in his life
you know um you know his his dad bailed
on him in the middle of the night
when my dad was five years old so he was
destined to repeat this pattern
he missed it by a year yeah you were
four nine
i know but he was destined because i i
i was i knew that this [ __ ] me up at a
young age i
wanted to get help i wanted to figure my
[ __ ] out
so i didn't do this again to my children
he didn't have that luxury you know it
was a different time
therapy was in a different place like he
didn't have a chance
and uh he said a lot of things about my
mom
and a lot of nice yeah yeah yeah really
nice and
it was an amazing it was an amazing time
so you forgave him oh yeah
big time and then we went out to moon
shadows about three months later and
then drank
a ton of beer and that's when it got
emotional actually he started to get
emotional and we were just
we went from hammering [ __ ] out
to some resolution to hammered to
hammered exactly
to now actually just having fun and him
seeing a lot of who he was in me
and me seeing a lot of who i am in him
you know and it was really an amazing
moment and now we have a relationship
you know so from that [ __ ] disastrous
post or seemingly disastrous post
came something really beautiful you know
i i commend you
and i think i commend you both really
but you know i mean there's two things i
would have thought about one is like
i mean it doesn't matter you have to
forgive you have to let go but it's like
you know you didn't have to repeat your
[ __ ] father what he did but you did
so it's like what do you do so you
either hold that grudge and say [ __ ] off
and go you know what
why do i want this there's something
deeper that i just want to
know more i want to like me you know why
go another 30 years or never
no no why not have these moments even if
it's just one moment that turned into a
couple moments for sure
and by the way when you look at when you
when you really get into it
how can how can i not forgive him how
can i not be compassionate when
when i look back on his life and what he
went through
as a kid with his mom and dad how can i
not
feel for him take myself out of the
equation that's the first thing i said
to him
when i when i saw him at patrick's
roadhouse right it was it was a little
small talk
you know and then i'm the one who was
like all right let's talk i mean this is
the first time i've seen you let's talk
and i said the first thing i want to say
is
let's just take take put aside that
you're my dad
and then i'm your son you and i are very
similar
how we have very similar stories had
bailed
my dad bailed we could sit here and talk
as friends and [ __ ] connect
and relate right now and i feel your
pain you know what i mean and and so
that's how it started and it was a good
place to start just a respect
exactly not in an angry place yeah let's
try to breathe through it let's
try to talk yeah you know yeah so
there's a lot i mean was your mom upset
about it
uh i mean when i went and was talking
because a lot of moms i know
people get mad they're like oh that
piece of [ __ ] that you're just gonna go
you've had this great father kurt's been
great you gotta go talk to him
but you know how people could think that
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because was
it was it
uh was it your mom who left bill i i
i don't even know i think i think so i
think so
right so i think so but no my mom was
not
no my mom has always been great with
this stuff
what did kate do uh that's a good
question my sister
you know she had a different
relationship with him she was younger
you know i mean i was a the boy and sort
of needed that father figure you know
maybe kate took a little bit more from
kurt than i did i
i don't know but kate uh kate doesn't
kate's not where i
kate wasn't where i was right kate's
totally content
you know not having a relationship with
him right
she hasn't right no no but she's she
there there's no animosity anymore
right you know there's no anger you know
you talk about this on sibling revelry
not really no do you ever talk about
this stuff uh
not like this but yeah i mean when i get
into heavy conversations or
deep conversations with people for sure
yeah i mean i'm not i
again it's like you said i'm open man i
i think it's important
stuff yeah yeah because i love how
candid open you are i mean it's it's
why not be what do i have to [ __ ]
hide
you know what i mean i mean there's
probably some things i don't want to say
yeah the only reason i wouldn't say
things
is just because i don't want other
people to
not want me to say them on sibling
revelry
we don't talk a lot about my mom
and kurt and the family dynamic that's
through on that show
well yeah for us you know there's some
things that we just
keep out of it because i know that you
know kurt doesn't want
things exposed and my mom doesn't want
things exposed and i'm not saying
there's anything
you know secret but just our lives
together
that's sort of special katie and i talk
about our relationship
you know the deep the depth of our
relationships
you know and you ever get mad at her on
the podcast do you ever literally
like you're [ __ ] annoying no but
sometimes i'll call her on her stuff you
know when kate gets
uh she'll get a little you know
high and mighty and i'll sort of have to
knock her off her pedestal a little bit
were
were you do you feel like you were ever
like jealous of her or like
envious like comparing yourself like why
did she get
[ __ ] almost famous you know why you
know yeah that's one of my one of my
biggest issues was
comparing myself to everyone yeah that's
it i think [ __ ] if you right now said
oh dude i i got the new scorsese thing i
would be happy for you but there's
definitely a part of me he's like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude what
but there's no i mean there's a
difference though there's a difference
if you're comparing yourself like
you know that guy has it so i should
have it you know that's not healthy
right and i
believe it's it's it's a learning curve
with anybody it's like
first of all you really i'm just
genuinely it feels so good when you can
go
i want you to be successful i want you
to do it but yeah of course there's
great when you can
feel that or but but really when you can
really feel that not
fake feel that because sometimes i have
to do that yeah sometimes i have to be
like
oh i'm so happy for you and then when i
start to
say it and force myself to say it i'll
start to feel it yeah but that initial
thing i'm like okay force yourself to
say it you know and then once i do
then i can i melt a little bit but no
for sure dude i mean others competition
and it's not jealousy as much as it is
envy she's had such an amazing career
and even wyatt right now
wyatt you know from the very beginning
he he
busted his groin and had too many
concussions and he comes home and he
goes on to be an actor and he's [ __ ]
immediately
at sundance in the first year with two
movies
you know i'm like you [ __ ] like yeah i'm
making money and i'm on a great
sitcom that's doing well but there's a
part of me that is envious of
their the creative that they get to be a
part of you know
they've done amazing things with amazing
people and you know wyatt did link
lighters movie
everybody wants some and he was in
austin texas for three weeks with all
the crew and writing with link glider
and
you know kate's with cameron crowe and
wyatt's doing all these cool independent
movies with real with visionaries you
know yeah you know people who are now
uber successful
it's a different trajectory people would
look at me
and and kill to have my career of course
you know but
you know it's it's all it's there's a
relativity there i look at them and i'm
you know
but but i want i want some of that the
more the more it's okay
that's okay but it is certainly it's
it's hard and we don't do it enough or i
guarantee you don't do this
nearly enough i'd say very little
where you just sit there for a minute by
yourself sit in your house
nobody's in the house or maybe they are
maybe uh the three little kids the
little amigos
they're running around they're kicking
something mm-hmm you know
aaron's you know in a bra i'm hoping
yeah i hope so and your
depends what kind of bra though uh
probably cotton
i know but here's the problem she's
she's gonna hate me for saying this but
but she's been wearing these
they're like armor bras it's like so you
know padded even though she's got
beautiful big boobs as you probably can
remember they're amazing
i got to the boobs to be honest
incredible i mean
really fanta i mean all times rub it in
buddy all the time
rub it but but she wears these sort of
more padded
things just to for you know i don't know
protect i don't know we know what to
take
those protect them and i'm listening
give me the lace again i
give me the soft stuff anyway you know
what keep playing subliminally
keep playing stevie nicks in the
background yeah leather and lace that's
all
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it should
start to go subconsciously it's like a
david blaine trick that's a good idea
you're gonna [ __ ] all of a sudden
you're like dude
what happened buzzing
yeah yeah and by the way i need to do
this more and i i have been
sit there and go god look at me man
i got this beautiful wife these three
kids
live in a nice house i like my parents
i got this relationship with my dad
got this cool podcast made a lot of
money
start i'm not i know it sounds stupid no
start just
saying these things out loud mm-hmm
just keep saying them and all of a
sudden you're going to realize
dude this is this is awesome yeah
and i think that's the more grateful we
are i was going to say graphics by the
way it's hard it's not as easy as you
think but it
but it is yeah it's science yeah if we
just like i do i'm doing this i'm
working so hard to just go
and i am i go hey you got a podcast
people listen to it they like it
i'm on patreon yeah i have patrons huh
hey [ __ ] uh i have a relationship
with my good relationship my friends i
have two great dogs
i sleep in a bed yeah if you just start
doing this you start realizing
and then when you start doing the
charity and stuff you start really like
god
um i'm not dying no
i'm alive i've got to stop comparing and
worrying and just live
and i think that's the thing for all of
us and i'm not i'm not preaching
no i'm telling you this i need to do
this oh by the way this is something
that everyone should do
especially ryan oh yeah i i don't
know him but he just looks like he needs
to be more grateful
you need to be more appreciative yeah
you do you're working
he's appreciative no but you're not
wrong dude and um
you know i write you know little words
of gratitude every day i do do that i
mean not every day but i
i when i have times of what the [ __ ] or
i need this or i need more money and
three kids at [ __ ] private school i
mean it's gnarly
yeah i'm like all right what's the worst
that can happen
here's the worst i sell everything and
move to [ __ ] colorado you know what
the worst thing is
i'll be happy you know you know what the
worst thing is i hate to say it but
think about it
because you know this is gonna air way
later mm-hmm but
kobe bryant i know dude this does
millions of dollars
has everything yeah gone i know
like that so horribly i mean if you
really think about it
if we just take today and just live this
day and do the best we can yeah
and try to have fun yeah and try not to
take things too seriously
i think that that's when our anxiety
sort of goes away
i think when you could just be happy
with yourself because i am trying to be
happy with myself i just had somebody
come over the house and i'm working on
stuff and
you know i i'm always looking for a
miracle but the miracle i
think probably lies within me what's
your biggest
like what's your biggest issue i think
pain i deal with a lot of pain
yeah so like actual physical physical
pain
oh yeah and i'm trying to like you know
because i've had surgeries and things
and i yeah and i don't talk about it
really right
um not a lot but don't you talk about it
because i don't no one wants to hear it
i'm trying to learn how to deal with but
i think a lot of it is emotional i think
oh i think not i think is it chronic
pain
yeah it's chronic pain it's been with me
for a while but it's it's gotten worse
and
um do you know like you wouldn't know
for the most part right but is it
undiagnosed pain
no i've had fusion in my neck i had a
botched surgery i had a
bunch of stuff okay but i've heard you
talk about that on a podcast
yeah like a little like a surgery i said
oh i had this surgery but that's right
what i'm saying is i don't sit there and
go
oh my god rob i'm in so much pain man i
can't deal with it i can't
i don't burden people with all that
stuff because i also
think you know you have all these great
things why should you burden which is
stupid it doesn't matter if you're a
good friend you're [ __ ] listening
because i listen to everybody's [ __ ]
problems right anybody has a problem
they come to me i'll [ __ ] help them
i'm always [ __ ] him there for my
friends me too
i'm not saying they're not there for me
they are but i think they assume that
i'm just
good which i should be but i'm not
because i'm
[ __ ] human and i'm neurotic and i've
got my [ __ ]
yeah and i'm not always good yeah you
saw me at thanksgiving break down a
little bit
i wasn't there well you didn't see it
you bro somebody should have taped it
to emotionally break down yeah i just uh
you know we'll talk about this on your
[ __ ] podcast
you you can't have me on there do you
have a
sibling yeah my brother so bring him on
ooh that would get
that would get crazy good i think people
would like that but i don't know man i
don't know if he's willing to talk about
like you know
his [ __ ] his [ __ ] we you know we don't
have to talk to him because i mean it
might come up and it's like you know
because he's yeah he's we
we worked together he was my assistant
for five years oh
and [ __ ] happened oh you got to bring
him on dude
it'll be great i mean it'll be great i
love him
kate's the great diffuser too you know
what i mean like yeah
and it's super chill like this dude i
love this i don't want this interview to
end and i haven't even
looked i haven't looked at this the
whole time this is the pages that i kind
of looked at
i just want to say this what if i just
went over i just want to say that i love
your mom and seems like old times
uh i love chubby chase's performance in
that and her performance now
you know what by the way that is uh one
of my mom
that's probably charles could be my
mom's my favorite movie that my
my mom has done it seems like old times
it is [ __ ] untouchable i love it so
much
i love that movie oh dude remember when
that's the end i'll tear up remember
when she just runs into his house yeah
yeah she's got that big smile freeze for
me
but look you you i mean i mean it's so
cool it's so
you know it's like you've heard every
story you've made every single day it's
probably not cool for you anymore
because it's like
people would say oh my god to be goldie
hawn it'd be kurt
russell was was he a good dad oh yeah i
mean
he he he i mean he changed the whole
direction of my life and the whole
dynamic of who i
who i might have been i mean if it
wasn't for kurt
i would not be the man that i am today a
hundred percent
he gave not only myself but my family
colorado
which is a huge part of my life and my
upbringing
you know he he taught me how to be
independent and
how to not be afraid and to
you know learn how to do things on my
own
and not rely on anyone else you know i
mean there's all kinds of lessons that's
that is just like
hearing that like i see your
relationship with your mom and i hear
this about kirk because i love i
remember i went up
uh curtin and goldie were at a party
that i was at and they were just
standing there and i just had seen this
movie bone tomahawk oh yeah and i just
i just had to because i'm a horror movie
fan and i just go hey
you're beautiful i love you and uh kurt
i just saw bone tomahawk i love it you
guys take care have a nice evening i
just wanted to say hi
i just i don't care i'm like i'm not
those actors are like oh i won't say hi
to someone [ __ ] you then why are you in
the business
right cause you're an actor [ __ ] you
right don't meet your [ __ ] heroes
go say hi to your heroes because you
know you die tomorrow you can go [ __ ]
you're not it's too cool yeah i [ __ ]
hate that
even i love stern and stern was on this
morning he's like i don't need to go up
to somebody
i don't need to go up here you know why
do you do that who doesn't yeah
because why not yeah yeah are you
bothering them yeah they're at a party
just to say i love you yeah whatever who
gives you nothing's wrong no i agree
but but your dad um when i say your dad
what do you
what am i supposed to say that's that's
it i call him we call him paw
paw i [ __ ] adore he was so sweet and
i was walking away because hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa come here come here
okay yeah he goes i love bone tomahawk
too let's talk about this
no why don't you like it and i go
because i thought it was really funny
and then got explosively dark and i got
caught up in these characters
i had no idea it was gonna and we just
started talking for like 20 minutes
about this awesome and he was just so
that's cool cool man that's actually
interesting because that doesn't sound
like kurt too much
really oh yeah what would he have done
in your eyes oh he's thank you
that's the end of it you know what i
mean he wanted to talk about it
that's interesting that's not that's not
him that's not like
tell him he won't watch this but tell
him my buddy just on his podcast i'm
telling you he'll remember yeah
so he came up to you at a party like a
year ago and he just said let's talk
bone tomahawk
and you sat there because he loved it so
much and you talked about yeah i loved
it too why didn't you love it yeah what
was it
and we talked about the splitting the
guy in half you saw it right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah that movie's intense yeah
anyway but i heard a story too that your
dad
or paul paul you're driving i just want
to add a couple little fun
stories here we've been real we've been
you know but you know that you were
driving with kate and
you're kurt's driving is this true your
mom's driving you know what i'm gonna
say
i don't yet and uh there's a truck
driver or something cutting them off
paint the picture yeah yeah yeah yeah go
ahead he
we were in hawaii and
we were just trying to get around this
big
semi-truck how old are you oh [ __ ]
little boy
yeah six seven no cause wyatt was alive
i think
so i was probably 12 i think something
so i remember
oh yeah yeah yeah okay and he
he the the the um the semi will not let
us
pass him and he's doing it on purpose
right so then
kurt goes over into the shoulder and
then pas
and then cuts in front of him and now we
come up to a stoplight
and the guy gets out of the car
and who's driving the truck and then
kirk gets out of the car
and it doesn't even flinch no because i
think that
if something was going to go down you
don't want to be in your car you want to
be up and out
so you know there's you have a better
chance he pulled over
yeah well it's at the stoplight okay and
the guy
kurt's like look you know i'm with the
family i was just trying to get by you
know defusing the whole thing and the
guy was just not having it
you know sort of poking curt doing
little shoves
big dude big like three plus hundred
pound guy
kurt went to go turn away just to get
out of the situation
and the guy just clocks him
and of course kurt doesn't go down
because his jaw's
made of a material that doesn't exist on
the earth
and he just lights him up but he
only goes to the body which was really
interesting
he went to the body and backed him up
into his truck
and then finished him off with a right
hand to the face
boom the guy i think he
kurt knocked a tooth out and he's
looking up and laughing at him and he
goes
kurt russell just knocked my teeth out
[Laughter]
and kurt comes back to the car and we
get in and we we cruise
that was that i heard obviously you know
the story i thought he said
i just got my tooth knocked out by snake
pliskim
oh maybe but whatever yeah one of the i
thought i think it was kurt russell
you saw him do this yeah could he throw
punches
oh yeah i think i kirk could try still
beat me up i mean
he might be anybody yeah he he's russell
he is
he's all you can handle he's a tough man
have you seen him but he's soft as she's
seen lose his temper
yeah of course yeah he's my dad you know
what i mean does he look like he's
does it like when he's in the movies
where he gets that stern yeah this is
what's gonna happen
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cause
he taps into that [ __ ] oh that's it
um oh god there's so many i love
backdraft for so many reasons oh yeah
bro i cry every time
i also love breakdown you ever see
breakdown
oh you got to see it it's a tight tight
movie with jt walsh
he's in it kurt plays a different kind
of character sort of a
like a how like a like a do good husband
who's driving
cross-country and they break down and
then it takes a really
bad turn what about the thing of course
dude those movies are in the sky
escape from escape from new york the
thing
you know he's done i mean he's done i
mean tombstone whenever tombstone's on i
just can't stop watching and then by the
way dude overboard oh one of the best so
it's like every time i'm i'm crying
every [ __ ] time
i cry yeah it's your mom yeah i know
well because when she when the kids when
she's leaving at the end
in the limousine and the kids are all
banging on the windows sort of saying
mom where are you going and she's
closing her ears because she can't hear
it i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's gnarly what's your favorite uh
goalie movie oh
man i mean private benjamin
um wildcats
love wildcats i was a kid on i was there
for a while yeah
yeah i remember i would uh wesley snipes
who that was like i think it was his
first movie
he we were he was my homie i mean wesley
was the coolest dude and i would be on
his shoulders running around
the thing and it was woody harrelson and
they were all like these newbie actors
that was fun that was fun in chicago
that was dope hey real quick these are
quick questions this is from uh some
patrons yeah
real quick lisa what was it like being
on the iconic dawson's creek because i
think he did like 18 episodes right any
stories from the
any quick story we do these rather
quickly um
i loved it dude i loved it because i
worked two days i had a house right on
the beach
i surfed every day and i met some really
good friends there and katie
katie holmes and i actually became good
friends and that that
sort of didn't make love yeah no we
didn't make love i was just
i was with aaron at the time oh yeah
good thing you didn't make love to her
yeah
lee stubbs i love to hate him on
nashville how did you feel about getting
killed off
i didn't like it but it was a necessity
i was lucky enough to be doing having
to do another show so they literally had
to kill me off they had no choice
christine who was your favorite actor to
work on scream queens uh
i'm gonna say glenn powell it's my boy
glenn powell i love glenn dude danny
oliver's work in lots of genres drama
comedy horror documentary does he have a
favorite type of role
probably comedy dark i like dark comedy
angel harrington i love the podcast
you're doing with your sister any chance
you'll work together an
acting project sometime soon yeah it'll
happen yeah yeah
matthew jasso snake pliskin or jack
burton
jack burton oh by the way that's the
other one big trouble in little china oh
yeah
that's one of my favorites that kurt has
done i mean that
that movie well it's another john
carpenter movie you know
anything john carpenter does you know i
heard something where it was like kurt
russell was uh
they were considering well they had a
i don't know if they have taylor i don't
know if this is true table reader
something for escape from new york
and they're like it's just that we got
to change it we got to make it more
likable
and he goes i'm likable right
i'm kurt russell right don't worry i'm
like
there's something true about that though
oh hell if you're likeable
you can make anything yeah i mean well
look at danny mcbride
right well i love him and everything he
has a hardship he's
despicable i mean he's despicable and
he's bounding down he's
despicable human but i'm i'm rooting for
him every single time
and that's just because that's his
nature yeah mary brock up i'm sure
you'll talk about what it was like
growing up with goldie hawn we did this
right home
i'm wondering about the series splitting
up together as a husband and father
himself
uh what did he think about the family
dynamics in the series at all
realistic yeah that's why i loved it i
mean it was my favorite thing that i've
done
because it actually touched upon
something real something that people
were going through
when i was doing press and stuff and
around after the show aired even
people come up to me like i'm going
through this or i have friends who are
doing this so it was
you know that's real i liked it for that
reason actually
jill eckhart does he get free fabletics
gear so you and your sister did a
athletic company right
well it's hers it's hers it's hers right
yes yes i do get it it's a good stuff
yeah it's good it's good they have
amazing men's line they just
launched a men's line that's what i look
good in blood yeah yeah
do you work out flab lettuce
karen bennett thinking back to justin
it really was what were your some of
your best memories of your family i mean
probably going to colorado is what you
said right what do you think yeah yeah i
mean
my fam we're we're a tight tight family
very close we all live within 10 minutes
from each other still well i'm glad
thanks for allowing me to
be inside of you today yeah dude really
you felt good it did
it felt really good it felt natural yeah
really um
is awesome maybe i'll ask him off but if
i totally like if i brought gave you
like a poster to get signed you'd do it
right
yeah of course like if i say hey can you
sign this [ __ ] like the thing poster
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's easy how
many friends of you have done that
zero are you serious yeah then they're
[ __ ] pretend time
yeah dude 100 percent that that's so no
one's ever done it so it's really not an
imposition [ __ ] 10
10 per poster now that you said that
i'll probably get you know
like seriously get whatever ones that
you want and they don't care
they don't my kid my dad doesn't give a
[ __ ] but yeah that's right
guys all right i might have him sign the
bone tomahawk
yeah what a great movie ryan you gotta
watch it dude this has been great i hope
you'll have me on your show and my
brother will will come on
sibling revelry sibling what else is
going on with your uh
i know you're not on twitter not on
twitter on instagram instagram what's
your handle
the oliver hudson the oliver hudson and
and
uh sibling rebel reasons at sibling
revelry
yeah listen to his pocket listen how
open was how much fun and it guys
if you like someone like i like i mean
look this is you obviously you're gonna
love this so
give that a shot and subscribe to his
show and kate
come on with yeah we'll [ __ ] with your
brother a little bit oh jesus
i love you buddy thanks love you too man
i loved it what do you think what was
your favorite thing about oliver hudson
favorite thing about oliver i mean
listening to him about that it was
really fun it was fun to talk uh
not talk i didn't talk at all it was
funny it was fun to listen to
yeah i was cutting it i was like oh
there was no break
yeah like it was constant like it was
like an hour and a half and it's going
to be shorter but you know yeah and you
listen
you have to listen cause you had it
because you have to make it tight and
get all the air out and all that
[ __ ] so
you really listen to all the episodes if
there's one person who really listens
it's you there was no error i was trying
to find because normally like i find
like a halfway point like okay this is
where the conversation shifts
it just like went it just went it just
went very fluid very very fluid
very fluid so again guys thank you if
you like this podcast
many more great ones to come you could
also revisit the old ones make sure you
subscribe
it's it's enormously helpful there's
some big news coming up when i can
announce that i will uh we're going to
be uh rob danson and i we do uh he's a
guitarist from left on laurel
uh he and i are doing an album together
we do stages once a month so look on my
uh instagram and all that stuff there's
great prizes and zooms and all that
and of course patreon thank you to all
my patreons um
out there who make this show possible uh
couldn't do it without you uh the stage
winners vicki garcia lisa jordan
thank you we play covers we play
originals we play a couple left on
laurel songs
oh and i'm doing the virtual thank you
for coming to the uh we did a
fan expo virtual thing where fans can
zoom me and and
there's one coming up make sure you're
looking on my instagram and
all that because tom wellington are
going to be doing some duo
zooms and more of these virtual
conventions which are interesting
and uh you know when you do a zoom with
me it's always like well
they say they're two minutes but i
always press the next you could there's
a button you could press
extra 10 seconds extra 10 seconds i feel
like i'm already giving people
twice their time half the time i mean
they're like um can we go to the next
one like no i'm not done talking to uh
john here
so thank you again for listening thank
you to everyone out there and uh you
know i'm gonna go ahead and read off the
uh the patrons which i always do
is there any way to make this
interesting maybe we can come up with
some interesting um
patreon music like a little guitar riff
after this where we could play something
and add it to this
sure sure sure here are the patron shout
outs
uh can do without you nancy d mary b
leah s
trisha f sarah v little lisa yukiko
jill e brian h lauren g nico p barry i
argentina my contacts are bad angelina
g uh robin s jerry w kevin r
emily k bob b robert b jason w steven j
kristen k
amelia oh allison l tom and jess n
lucas m raj joshua d emily s cjp
cjp samantha m humza
b jennifer n stacy b carly t rheem
jennifer s janelle b taba the 272
kimberly e melissa c mike
e marissa and jude d ramirez beth b
chris f sarah f chad w lee np jackie p
rodrigo
rodrigo s ration ragin russian
ray a maya p megan d jennifer c m mattie
s
tiffany i kendrick f ashley e
margie m sigourney p thomas t matt w
belinda
and we're almost done benjamin are lisa
j
kevin v robert s joy w
thanks everyone out there this has been
a joy to do i want to keep doing this
podcast
i do my best i call every guest i get
every guest uh hopefully i'm gonna get
some help in a little while
in a little bit to help me get more
guests but when people say can you get
so and so on
well i have to know him or know someone
or i i do my best i've called agents
i've done that thing and i'm like oh my
god here i am i'm that guy
hey you know and then sometimes calling
guests like i was calling jensen apples
again i'm jensen hey
did it's rosie again hey and then then
you use me i was like dude dude i'm so
sorry blah blah and i thought you know i
was like he's probably ignored he's
probably [ __ ] off i think i just emailed
karen gillan again
you know she's probably oh god it's like
shut the [ __ ] up
you know but like i gotta try i love
doing this and it helps people and i'm
gonna [ __ ] keep doing it
sorry for the f-bombs ryan anything you
got going on
uh no no
well you know i'm glad you're doing this
so thank you yeah
all right guys thank you for allowing me
to be inside each and every one of you
uh till next time uh you know just take
care of yourself
do the best you can or a mask be
respectful
[Music]
you